Many years ago in Japan, a farmer and his wife had three children, two boys and a girl.
The girl was small and not very strong. She was often sick.
She spent her time drawing cats.
Her mother told her father one day,...
"She is no use to us. Let's take her to the temple."
"She can become a nun and live at the temple."
The girl went to live at the temple.
She drew cats at all times of the day and night.
One of the other nuns said,...
"You are not the kind of young woman we want here."
"I must ask you to leave the temple."
The girl left the temple. She did not have any money,...
...and she did not want to go back to the farm.
"I will sell some of my drawings of cats," she thought.
It was night by the time she came to a town.
Just outside the town, there was a large temple.
It was very quiet. "I will stay here tonight," she thought.
The temple was quiet because only a dangerous goblin lived in the temple.
She knocked on the door, but no one came.
The girl wanted to sleep, but she also wanted to draw some cats.
When the screen was full of cats, she lay down and went to sleep.
The girl slept until about the middle of the night.
Then she heard a terrible noise. The noises did not stop until morning.
There was a very large dead rat in the middle of the room.
The girl knew that it was a goblin rat.
"Something very big and strong killed that rat," she thought.
She saw the large paper screen. It was covered with her drawings of cats.
Their mouths were red with blood.
"My cat drawings came to life in the night," she thought.
"They saved me from the goblin rat."
She left the temple and went on her way.
Everywhere she went, people wanted to buy her cat drawings from her.
Soon, she became one of the most famous artists in Japan.